meantime just two decades ago there were
only four MPs from black and minority
ethnic backgrounds today there are more
than 50 of them and one man has played a
pivotal role in boosting black
representation in politics here Simon
Wooley has led the campaign organization
operation black vote for 23 years he's
now so Simon after being recognized in
the Queen's Birthday Honours for the
work he's done as a race and equality as
activists but the knighthood came as a
bit of a surprise given this sometimes
controversial work he's done in
highlighting race discrimination as you
can see the Simon joins us now hello to
use nice to see you thanks for coming
and congratulations very much a surprise
for you very surprised I mean this is
not supposed to happen to kids that have
brought up on a council estate to be
knighted to be to have that title in
front of their name years later but here
it is it's it's a bit overwhelming what
happened got the letter and I showed my
son his jaw dropped as did mine and he
said to me you're the big boys dad yeah
so we our son we are too and so we'll go
to the palace and get a suit and go on
one day and be knighted by by the Queen
and is it the Queen that I'm not sure
okay sure I've known a few weeks time
okay you must have been surprised though
given that you have taken on the
establishment on more than one occasion
that's right I mean that's now roll I
mean our role is to challenge the
establishment to make sure it's more
inclusive more representative and that
means often crossing swords campaign in
protesting pointing the finger and so of
being an outsider you never expect to be
recognized by the very institutions that
you've challenged over two decades but I
guess it's a recognition and the way
things are changing that they're now
looking at people who have sought to
transform our society our institutions
to bring communities in who didn't have
a voice and to make our society much
better tell us about your work well it's
been for over two decades and given
people a voice challenging persistent
inequality in jobs in education in
Parliament you know taking it from for
any piece to over for over 50 and I
think that the Parliament is better
for work like this you know when there's
more women when there's more minority
voices the debate the debate is better
but it's not just about Parliament you
know it's about all facets of our
society of business for example you know
we often argue that diversity works when
you have more diversity around the board
table looking at our diverse society
global economy it's much better but when
people feel included do you feel that it
has become easier to achieve that over
time I think so I mean you know we'd
like to see ourselves as really
disciples of dr. Martin Luther King you
know he had a dream bid he had more than
a dream he had a plan and his plan was
to empower African Americans to advance
progress and we think we're on that
trajectory it's gotten easier but
sometimes you can go forward in a little
bit backwards I think austerity over the
last 10 years and brexit there's been a
strain as xenophobic strain that has
been unleashed
which needs to be challenged and so you
have to be vigilant you have to keep
your foot on the pedal take people with
you that was gonna be my question and we
give him the way that politics is at the
moment to you finding that more
challenging sometimes I mean the climate
the climate has been a bit a bit rotten
in some places you know that that I was
brought up in an era when they would say
send their walks to Vietnam and and that
was pretty brutal
and yet fast-forward 40 50 years and my
son is being called the n-word you know
when he plays for tonight online I mean
it's become sadly it's become more
legitimized
that the level of racism I think due to
a certain strain in Brooks I'm not
blaming brexit in total but there's a
strain so you have to be vigilant but
you know when we look at our businesses
when we look at Parliament when we look
at local authorities London Bristol
herring again you see black leaders male
and female that the change is there to
be seen but I'm impatient I think
there's a deluge a talent that's just
waiting to fulfill its potential and so
I want leaders on what leaders in the
media that leaders in other business
community in politics in medicine to
wreck
nice the the deluge a talent that just
needs a pathway and everybody benefits
is your vigilance taking and what can
others do to try to help yeah well I've
been lucky working with the prime
minister of last 18 months we convinced
her to undertake a race disparity unit
audit to look at how why clip white old
and his policies are reflecting minority
communities does it work what's not
working and her mantra was explain the
inequalities or change and that's been a
fantastic framework for which to hold
ministers to account I hope it carries
on I mean you know she's not there much
longer the framework is I want all
parties to say this works for race works
for gender it can work for people of
disability but it needs leadership it
needs people to say we acknowledge the
challenge and we need drivers are both
from the very top in the middle and
beloved - do you have a thought on which
Prime Minister you think you would be
able to work with the best no no I don't
I I want them to I want them to see
certain things I think like gender like
like race like poverty are above party
politics and anybody go into that famous
door or to recognize that yes certain
politics is tribal and and bloody brutal
but the certain issues are beyond it and
if you can get leaders to kind of say
this is this is beyond this all leaders
need to work together then we can get to
a better place sooner rather than later
although some of our politicians some of
the comments that they've made yeah you
wouldn't be comfortable with not at all
and look it's my job not to tiptoe
around when someone's wrong I'll point
the finger and hold them to account
whether they like it or not I mean they
can say we're not talking to you or this
third in the other but but I won't shy
away and going on a March in a couple of
weeks time against win rush in the wind
Russ candor has been appalling
frankly my mother's my mother's
generation she came here as a young
woman worked in the hospitals all adult
life and to have her generation to be to
be challenged the way they are whether
there are citizens or not
is frankly appalling so whatever needs
to be said I won't be afraid to say it
but you would align yourself with
somebody like Sajid Javid more than
potentially Boris Johnson I'm not
getting into names I'll get it what I
want is we have an agenda we have a
manifesto I want all the leaders to look
at it and sign up to it and then we'll
see how they behave whether or not and
how we hold them to account ever met
Nigel Faraj no I haven't it did write it
was in the early days I think he tried
to you know quarters in some ways but
some of the things he said and some of
the some of the kind of the dog
whistling stuff I've not been happy with
and you know I
so I've steered away have you told him
oh yes he knows he knows exactly how I
feel do more yeah I mean he's I've
written about him I've spoken to his
allies so you know he knows that the dog
whistling stuff that this xenophobic
genie this anti immigrant when my
mother's generation and the generations
the Asian generations and others that
Kate have made this country dynamic both
home and abroad and and I rail against
those that that point the finger at
immigrants in such a negative way when I
think we've made a great contribution
and we can make an even more greater
contribution if those pathways to
equality are laid I laid there tell us
about your background you say mum was
the Windrush generation she was a nurse
she was a nurse yes I was lucky Kate I
had two mothers so I had a bob agent
mother but I was also fostered and
adopted by a Welsh mother and Irish
father who in many ways have made me
what I am today they filled me with love
and affection and the belief that I
could do anything I've reconnected with
my birth mother now and that's rather
special how's that special I mean you
know this is pain this tears but there's
a connection she's my she's my mother
she had to make difficult decisions but
I was lucky I mean you know it's a
longer debate really but I was lucky
because because I was in a home full of
love
and so we still go to Wales in the the
Rhondda Valley mean me and my
half-brother two black kids in in the
white valleys of Wales yeah
so a bit of an oddity but you know it's
Who I am today what advice would you
give to others who are you know I was
gonna say struggling but I don't mean
struggling I mean making looking to make
their mark right to believe to you know
it's not where you start from is where
you go
and it's how you believe in yourself and
I think that that anyone thinks this is
a walk in the park it isn't but if you
can find some inner strength and belief
and it are supported whether it's by
friends or family there should be no
limits you know that here I'm speaking
to you today so Simon William it's a bit
it's a bit mind-boggling but it's true
and I want other particularly
working-class kids black and white to
have that vision and belief with hard
work and endeavour that there's no
limits are you gonna use your prefix I
don't know I don't know you know because
it's it's a bit daunting I think when I
want door to open to change our wealth
yeah then I will but I won't use it for
to get a better table at a restaurant
oh come on come on I'll get a cab I'll
get a cab I'll get a cab maybe maybe
that if I'm flying a long-distance oh
that what a trick but you know look I
think you know seriously but but with
coming from working-class and good
friends they'll keep me grounded
yeah so if I start getting puffed up
they'll say Wally behave yourself yeah
and what the first thing you're gonna do
once you've got your measure I guess I
want my family friends and family to
enjoy it and actually I've been
overwhelmed by the community response I
mean that the deluge of love and warmth
often only comes to people when they die
and so it's nice to get it right now
yeah but I think in many ways kay that
they're showing in this because it's
about struggle because it's about
breaking down barriers and many people
have been with me on this journey they
feel it's their success too that's
that's pretty special